this is about my universe
[Music]
and she's here
[Music]
that's chris martin dedicating his new
song to girlfriend dakota johnson it was
really special special indeed and also a
pretty brilliant plug for his latest
single with coldplay the song is called
my universe
[Music]
and yeah that's k-pop phenomenon bts
collabing on this track how do you top
this feeling i don't think it's possible
following the sweet tribute chris and
dakota were also spotted together on
wednesday photog snapped the couple
heading to the uk premiere of dakota's
film the lost daughter which streams on
netflix later this year but back to that
sweet concert moment
[Music]
thoughtful as ever chris also brought a
special guest for the audience ed
sheeran who joined the band on stage it
was a real
real special moment
chris has been busy getting the word out
about his new song including an
unplugged performance on the kelly
clarkson show last month
the rock singer even performed bts's
part in korean what i mean
[Music]
chris also chatted with zane lowe on
apple music one where he opened up about
the song's origins it's a love song yes
that came from
a loving text it had been in my mind for
a while that someone had said
bts
or wondering if we'd do a song for them
or something something like that
and um
the phrase my universe
in this text was that oh that's a cool
song title
[Music]